cspan's american history tv continues
now you can find the full schedule for
the weekend on your program guide or at
cspan.org
history
flying west across the pacific vice
president and mrs richard nixon began
their tour of six nations that was to
take them completely around the world
their first destination was manila
the busy capital of the philippines was
like the rest of the country tense with
excitement on the eve of a great
national celebration
the 10th anniversary of independence
[Music]
on the afternoon of july 3rd mr and mrs
nixon landed at international airport
vice president carlos garcia of the
republic of the philippines was there to
welcome them
high-ranking members of the philippine
government of congress and of the armed
forces also extended their greetings
the warmth of the reception was
everywhere
this was more than just a visit of state
by the second highest official of the us
government
it was a gesture of the mutual esteem
between americans and filipinos
several times along dewey boulevard the
visitor halted the cavalcade to
acknowledge the tremendous cordiality
shown him
brief ceremonies outside malacanang
palace mr garcia accompanied the honored
guests to where president and mrs ramon
magsaysay awaited them
this again was more than a mere visit it
was a warm reunion between old friends
on the morning of the 4th of july a day
glorious to both filipinos and americans
mr nixon later wreath at the monument of
jose rizal
the filipino patriot and martyr whose
name is known to millions who cherish
freedom
the solemn moment brought memories to
all present for it was exactly ten years
earlier on this very site that the late
president manuel rojas had first raised
the flag of the new philippines republic
[Music]
once more the innate friendliness of the
u.s vice president was expressed to the
many many people who'd come to see and
to greet him
[Music]
[Applause]
but now the moment for the greatest
event had arrived
over a half million people were gathered
at lunetta park when president and mrs
magsize joined ex-president sergio
osmena and mr and mrs nixon to review a
mammoth parade
this was the exuberant climax of the
nationwide celebration of this tenth
year of independence
in the two-hour long procession more
than 50 huge floats rolled by
they depicted philippine progress in the
past decade and they pointed to the
future goals of this country a country
that not so long ago was left crushed
and shattered by war
[Music]
overhead planes spelled out philippine
independence 10 years
and on the ground military units marched
smartly in review
[Music]
every branch of the island republic's
armed services took part in this giant
demonstration of patriotic spirits
[Music]
by permission of president max heisei
the huge crowd was allowed to surge
forward at the parade's end the better
to hear the address of vice president
nixon
i have witnessed many fourth of july
parades
i have seen parades with
many floats and many bands
but in all my life i have never seen a
parade to equal the one the philippines
put on today
we in the united states in our early
years had the problem
of our tories
who were still loyal to a foreign ruler
but your problem in the philippines
was a far greater one
the authority of your government was
challenged by the hawks
now many of these rebels
as you know
were simple people
probably the great majority of them were
but they were led astray
by their
leaders but you also know
that among the leaders were men
who were not truly filipinos
because they owed their first allegiance
not to the philippine government but to
the materialistic ruthless foreign
ideology of communist colonial
imperialism
and what did you do about it
and this to me is one of the great
stories of this republic
and one that should be told and retold
all over the world
it's true that you used military force
where necessary in dealing with the hux
but
you also did something
perhaps even more important
you removed the political and economic
causes of discontent
and in this effort
your president
raymond magsaysai
played a leading part and for this
believe me
president magsaysay has won the
admiration of the whole free world
i know that there are those
who feel that friendly neutrality
towards the kremlin
and p ping
may spare them
but you know there is an old proverb
and it is that he who stops with the
devil
must have a long spoon
the communists have been ruthless
toward the people of the nations they
have engulfed
they have no memory of former favors
no kindness toward those who tried to be
friendly
they are cold and calculating mastery
and those who feel that they can out
maneuver them
are taking a fearful risk
we hope that all the nations of asia
will understand
our attitude toward collective security
and may i say at this point that
i appreciate particularly the fact that
with the rain coming down so many of you
still will stand there and listen as we
finish our speech
may i thank you for listening so
patiently
and may i say to you
that as was the case three years ago
mrs nixon and i
have been deeply touched by the welcome
that we have received all over your
country
i trust
that the years ahead
we'll see the republic of the
philippines make even greater progress
in the next 10 years than in the last 10
my boo
next day president magsaysai and vice
president nixon visited corregidor
its long silent guns
remain a memorial to the brave men who
defended this island fortress
corregidor is a bond between two nations
for it was here that filipinos and
americans fought and died side by side
malenta tunnel was also toured by the
leaders who shared vivid impressions of
its historic past
it was here that living quarters had
been provided for the first philippines
president manuel quezon
and it was here the generals macarthur
and wainwright planned their strategy
president magsaisai arranged this trip
at the request of mr nixon who wished to
see for himself the hardships that the
defenders of democracy had experienced
[Music]
next day manila's national press club
specially adorned for the visitors from
washington became the vice president's
final stop before he flew to saigon
this too provided a reunion with men
whom he hadn't seen in three years
during a half-hour interview he
impressed the news men by his frankness
in discussing controversial issues
of particular interest to them was his
assurance that title to us military
bases would be returned to the
philippines
[Music]
later that morning in the wake of a
monsoon rain vice president and mrs
nixon arrived in the capital of south
vietnam
u.s ambassador frederick reinhardt
representatives of president ziem and a
throng of vietnamese citizens greeted
them
in no other place were the nixons to see
a greater change since their previous
visit to asia
then this land had been in the throes of
war
today it was a free and peaceful
republic
while riding into saigon signs over the
road testified to the friendship vietnam
feels toward the american people and
their elected representatives
this happened to be a time of national
rejoicing
everywhere there were people carrying
banners marching in celebration of the
second anniversary of engojin gems
presidency
thousands gathered on the spacious lawn
before the presidential palace to cheer
the republic and president in godzilla
jim when mr nixon came to be received by
the young nation's chief executive
[Music]
the two leaders conferred for an hour
and a half mr nixon extended president
eisenhower's warmest personal
congratulations well earned by a man and
his people who had shown astonishing
progress and spirit through two
difficult years
[Music]
at president diem's invitation the
visitor from washington joined him in
facing the vast assemblage outside
speaking extemporaneously to his
cheering countrymen
jim thanked them for their splendid
unity which he feels has been
responsible for the success their nation
has achieved
he also thanked the united states
through its vice president for its help
not only to vietnam but to the entire
free world
in response mr nixon told his hosts that
america was proud indeed to be vietnam's
friend and alive
another high point occurred at the
vietnamese national constituent assembly
the u.s vice president became the first
guest speaker ever invited to appear
before this body for mr nixon this
privilege had special significance for
back in america he'd served many years
as a legislator
to the representatives of the vietnamese
people he expressed his admiration for
the accomplishments that have marked the
first two years of president jim's
administration
he further told the delegates that
although their country was divided here
in south vietnam the militant march of
communism had been halted and from this
the free world derived great inspiration
[Music]
a visit to the honai refugee
resettlement area was another
opportunity for mr nixon to see the
extraordinary job vietnam is doing in
rehabilitating the hundreds of thousands
who fled the communist north
being a father himself he especially
enjoyed meeting the children
there were handshakes too for their
elders for the parents and the aged
who'd given up all they had to escape
communist tyranny and live in a land
that offered liberty
the vice president met the roman
catholic priests and others who had
worked long and selflessly to make this
camp a living and a growing thing
he saw new farm equipment made available
through united states assistance
he saw a deeply religious people
awaiting distribution of these tools
after their blessing by a bishop who was
a refugee from tonkin
it was an unforgettable experience for
the vice president
he felt he was witnessing here one of
the great stories of southeast asia the
story of south vietnam's fight for
freedom
and a better life for all
[Music]
on the evening of july 7th vice
president and mrs nixon arrived in
taiwan
at taipei airport u.s ambassador carl
rankin chinese vice president chen cheng
foreign minister george yay and premier
oku were among the first to welcome them
[Music]
also gathered to greet the personal
representative of president eisenhower
were important chinese government
officials and members of the diplomatic
corps
[Music]
the vice president's visit was
tremendously heartening to the capital
of nationalist china as evidenced by the
people's cheers
the next day he conferred with president
chiang kai-shek after giving him a
letter from president eisenhower a
letter that strongly reassured free
china's leader and his people of
steadfast u.s support in their stand
against communism with mrs nixon and
madame chang the two statesmen posed for
news cameraman
mr nixon summed up the content of their
talks in a brief statement
i just had a conference with president
xiang with regard to the relations
between the government of the united
states and the government of the
republic of china
and
in this conference we discussed the
mutual problems and the mutual dangers
which we confront in the world
the
government of the united states and the
people of the united states
stand firmly with the government of the
republic of china and the people of the
republic of china against communist
aggression in asia and other parts of
the world
as a result of this conference
i am sure that there will be no doubt
in the minds of people around the world
that our two countries and our two
peoples stand together against the
common danger which threatens three
people around the world the danger of
communist imperial colonialism
writing back to the airport the vice
president and his party were hailed by
thousands of chinese young and old who
lined the streets of
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
an taipei guard of honor was at the
airport to pay their country's respects
to the distinguished guests
these were crack contingents of
nationalist china's superbly trained
fighting forces
an unexpected delay caused by the
blowout of an airplane tire postponed
the departure
after further talks with chinese and u.s
officials vice president and mrs nixon
and planed for thailand six hours behind
schedule
it was close to midnight when they
arrived in bangkok
thai prime minister people son graham
and his wife greeted them with a
traditional charm for which their land
is famous
they were also greeted by u.s ambassador
max waldo bishop and other members of
the diplomatic corps
leading his guest into a reception room
at don muang airport the prime minister
added a formal welcome of his own
as foreign minister prince wan and other
dignitaries looked on the premier
recalled how warmly he had been received
during his own visit to america just a
year before
and he regretted that there wasn't time
enough to entertain his american friends
appropriately
in reply the us vice president insisted
that the welcome was much more than
adequate and he expressed deep
gratefulness that so many of thailand's
leaders should be kind enough to turn up
and meet him when he had been obliged to
come at so late an hour
in a dining room prepared for the
occasion the prime minister and mr nixon
and their party partook of a midnight
dinner
one more example of thailand's
hospitality to the american goodwill
ambassador
once again mr nixon held a press
conference he underscored america's
strong backing of the southeast asia
treaty organization
thailand and the united states he
declared will continue their efforts for
economic development and social
well-being so that all may pursue lives
in peace and happiness
then a last goodbye from prime minister
peeben sangram before his departure for
pakistan
[Music]
later that very morning his air force
transport reached karachi two of
pakistan's top cabinet members aya
chundraga and habib ibrahim rahim tula
welcomed the nixons to another seto
nation
the eighth punjab regiment provided the
honor guard
mr chundraga took the salute with vice
president nixon in the absence of prime
minister muhammad ali who was away in
london for the commonwealth conference
with the united states charged affair
arthur gardiner the vice president and
mrs nixon met more than 50 members of
the foreign diplomatic corps
karachi was another place that greatly
impressed mr nixon for tremendous
developments had taken place since last
he visited the capital
the cameraman accompanying the vice
president took these views of the city's
buildings
they are dramatic reminders of
pakistan's energy and determination
at the presidential palace mounted
rangers and white tunics provided a
colorful escort for the callers from the
united states
inside mr nixon posed with president
iskandar merza and cabaret ministers
after conferring with them on matters of
military and economic aid while mrs
nixon chatted with a charming and
gracious begum mercer
before leaving karachi the u.s vice
president granted another press
conference
on the question of kashmir he said the
united states hoped for a settlement by
direct india-pakistan talks or failing
that
through the united nations
it was at this press conference that he
warned countries of the free world
against accepting soviet aid the
communists price he said could be a rope
around their necks
unlike u.s assistance which is given to
maintain freedom aid from russia could
spell its end
after four hours in karachi the nixon's
plane departed swinging west toward the
capital of turkey
it was night when vice president and mrs
nixon arrived at ankara's snboa airport
both turkey's president jalal bayar and
her premier adnan menderes welcomed the
personal emissary of president
eisenhower mr bayar who recalled mr
nixon's hospitality when he himself
visited washington insisted that the
vice president and his wife be his
personal guests
[Music]
next day there were more of those chance
meetings with ordinary people a brief
chat with a young turkish news boy
brought out his deep interest in america
and his affection for president
eisenhower
these were feelings that mr nixon
noticed everywhere he went and in people
from widely different backgrounds and
national origins
[Music]
one of the most impressive moments of
vice president nixon's stay in the
turkish capital was his laying of a
wreath at the tomb of kemal ataturk the
founder of modern turkey
the second highest official of the
united states government paid a solemn
salute to the memory of one of the most
extraordinary leaders of this century
driving back to the city enroute to the
airport the american vice president's
motorcade stopped in the center of uluz
an ancient historic part of ankara
this gave mr nixon the opportunity once
more to meet the people he stepped out
and shook hands with many persons who
quickly surrounded his car
[Music]
at the airport there was one last
friendly touch
vice president and mrs nixon had a
personal goodbye for the police officers
who escorted them
a final farewell from the chief of the
national assembly and from premier
mandarin for whom mr nixon carried a
message to president eisenhower
then the vice president's plane turned
westward once more over the capital city
and over turkey that ancient land which
is at once so modern too
[Music]
at palma in the spanish mediterranean
island of mallorca the plane stopped
briefly to refuel vice president nixon
was greeted by the u.s ambassador to
spain john lodge and by spanish foreign
minister alberto martinez
last refueling stop was bermuda in the
mid-atlantic then 11 days after they had
left home vice president and mrs nixon
returned to washington
a large crowd greeted them including
senator noland and secretary of state
dulles
and historic tour was over
reassurances of east west friendship had
been made around the world especially
with six nations whom the united states
is proud to call partners in the
struggle for freedom
weekends on c-span 2